Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 7, More on Loops.
So we're going to continue with what we talked about on chapter 6, on lecture 6, where you were introduced to loops.
Now, many programmers think that writing loops correctly is a matter of luck or trial and error or magic.
It's like a holy grail. That is not actually the case. It's easy to consistently write loops that are correct, that work the first time.
You just have to learn how. Unless you're taught how to do it, you won't do it correctly. It's not natural.
Now I learned the technique that I'm going to teach you back in the 1980s when I first started programming.
This was developed by a professor at Berkeley named Doug Cooper, who wrote the book "O Pascal".
It's helped me as a programmer more than any other thing that I learned in school.
And I hope that you'll spend the time to kind of internalize these techniques and make them useful for you.
Now first, when we think about a loop, we need to think about two things.
Here's a simple problem specification that requires a loop.
I want you to count the number of characters in a sentence that ends with a period.
Count the number of characters in a sentence that ends with a period. Include the period in the count.
Now, the goal is what the loop is trying to accomplish. What work are we trying to produce?
What information are we trying to discover? Our goal here is to produce a count of the entire characters in a sentence.
How long is this sentence including the period at the end of it?
The bounds is what makes the loop stop. So this loop will stop when it encounters a period.
So when we found a period, we're done. We don't need the loop anymore.
And the plan is a set of steps needed to reach our goal.
So here's a plan. Let's read the first character. While the character is not a period, count the character.
Then read the next character.
Now, once you have the plan and the goal and the bounds, you need to think about where to put those parts in your loop.
So this is called the loop's topology. If you look at the loop on the right, you'll see four different sections.
There's something that happens before the loop. There's a loop test condition. There's a loop body.
And then there's something that happens after the loop. And we have some vocabulary for this as well.
The actions that occur before the loop, whether associated with the goal or the bounds, are called the loop's preconditions.
Stuff that happens before we encounter the loop.
The actions that control the loop, the test part, is called the loop's bounds. That's what stops the loop.
The actions that take place in the body are the operations of the loop.
That can include advancing the loop or updating the variables in the loop's goal.
And the actions that occur after the loop is over are called the loop's postcondition.
So let's look at how we'd put that to work.
First, we're going to look at the steps that are required to make the loop go around.
In this part, you want to think only about what makes the loop work, not that the work that the loop does.
So you're not thinking at all about whether you're counting or printing or anything like that.
Just what makes the loop work.
The first question you always have to ask, and the first piece of code you will always write, is the loop's bounds.
What makes the loop stop?
So in our case, if we're counting the letters in a period, we'd say "while letter is not a period."
Well, that's good. If I write that down in code, "while letter not equal to period," my code won't compile.
So that brings us to step two.
So the loop bounds is done in that second section.
So let me just go back to here. That's where the loop bounds is done.
The second part is figuring out what it takes to enter the loop.
What setup is needed to allow us to run this bounds condition?
This is called the bounds precondition.
So what setup is needed for this to be syntactically correct?
In our case, here's the string we're checking, str.
This is pseudocode. The little arrow means set string to the string to check.
Set letter to the first character in string.
And here's our bounds condition, "while the letter is not a period."
And so now if we translated that to C++ code, our program would compile and it would run.
But it would continue running forever.
As long as the first character was not a period, when we went back again, letter would still be the first character.
And so the third step in the mechanical part of getting your loop to work is advancing the loop.
Moving it from the setup or startup condition towards the bounds.
In our case, inside the body of the loop, we'd have to set the letter to the next character in string.
Whether we do that in a counter, whether we do it some other way, that's immaterial.
In the plan, all we need to do is make sure the letter is the next character in string.
Now we have a loop that runs, goes through the correct number of times,
and all we have to think about is, now what do I do for the work?
What do I do to reach my goal?
So part two, doing the work, is trying to reach our goal.
And the goal of every loop is to produce some information.
In our case, the goal of our loop is to produce the count of the characters in a sentence.
The count of the characters in a sentence.
So first, you go back to that top section, the precondition section,
and you create a variable to hold the answer.
This is called the goal precondition.
So here I'd come back up above those two variables I already created,
and I'd create another variable, count.
That'll be the result of the loop. That'll hold the answer.
Secondly, or fifth, step five actually,
what work do you need to do to update those variables?
This is the loop operation.
Well in our case, every time we get in the loop, before we go to the next character,
we need to update the goal.
We need to update the goal.
So do the work required to update the variables.
This is in the body, this is in the loop operation.
Now, the loop's finished, have we reached our goal?
You always have to answer that question after the loop is over.
You have always reached your bounds.
In other words, we have always encountered a period.
But, have we counted the period yet?
No, we haven't. So we haven't reached our goal,
we haven't counted the number of characters in a sentence, including the period.
And so after the loop is over, we'd have to count the period itself.
So make sure when you're writing these loops that you always ask yourself these six questions,
including the last one.
Have I reached my goal? Is the answer I have the correct answer?
Okay, so that's really short. There's more information in the text.
I hope you'll read it, and I hope you'll spend some time engaging in it.
It's not really a hands-on exercise, but it's something that will make your programming much, much easier.
Okay, so let's go now and talk about necessary and intentional bounds.
Suppose we have a string that contains 123.25,
and we want to extract just the integer portion, just the 123 part.
We'd write a loop, and we'd write a sentinel loop,
and the loop would stop when we find the period, the sentinel.
So this is just similar to what we just talked about.
This bounds condition is called the intentional bounds.
We intend to stop when we find a period.
So here is the loop in code, size T, I equals zero.
Because it's a sentinel loop, we'll write it as an indefinite loop using while.
While str at I is not equal to the period, plus plus I.
This works perfectly fine, it's perfectly correct, except what if the string doesn't contain a period?
In that case, our program will crash.
And so you always need to ask yourself while you're writing the loop bounds,
will this work for any possible input?
Will it work for the empty string?
Will it work for a negative number?
That sort of thing.
So in this case, if the string doesn't contain a period,
we need to add a second bounds condition called the necessary bounds.
The necessary bounds is what's required if you don't find your intentional bounds.
And so here, we'd add a necessary bounds with an and statement before our intentional bounds.
Notice we're going to keep going while I is less than or equal to the string size,
and the string at I is not equal to the period.
We're going to keep counting in that case, or we're going to keep incrementing.
Now, the break statement jumps out of a switch or a loop.
In a loop, break jumps from inside this if statement all the way out to the first statement,
following the loop's body.
And as you saw in lecture six, this can make your code clearer when you use it to construct a loop and a half.
Again, as in lecture six, I mentioned this is available in languages like Ada,
where they use the syntax exit when.
In C++, we create an exit when with an if statement along with a break.
Now, I should mention that in a loop, you should only have a break inside an if statement.
If you have a break outside of an if statement,
it will just create some code that is non-executable or unreachable code.
So, notice there's a slight difference here between the previous algorithm.
In this algorithm, we put the necessary bounds in the loop condition.
So, we're going to keep going while I is less than the string size.
We put the intentional bounds inside an if statement.
So, if str@i equals the period, we're done and break.
The big difference is that when you write a loop and a half,
your intentional bounds, the part that's in the if statement inside the loop,
is written as a positive statement.
It tells you what you need to do to get out of the loop.
So, notice this says str@i equals equals period,
whereas when we wrote it as part of the condition here,
we said str@i not equal to period.
So, in the condition, we're saying what's required to keep going.
In the loop and a half, we're saying what's required to get out of the loop.
What's required to get out of the loop.
Now, the continue statement is similar to a break.
Both continue and break are forms of controlled jump statements.
The continue statement, instead of leaving the loop, starts the next iteration.
So, here's a while loop.
We have an if statement. Again, like break, continue should only appear inside an if statement.
And we have one condition that will keep the loop going.
And if we have another condition, we're going to skip up back to the original condition.
Now, why would we want to do that?
We'd want to do that if the condition we're setting here is some kind of error condition.
That means that down here at the bottom, I can process the data we're processing
without having an if and an else statement here.
So, this is, again, a shorthand.
In the for statement, the continue will jump not to the condition, not to the end less than 10,
but to the update expression.
And while, it jumps right up to the test condition.
So, we're going to put this to work.
We're only going to do one exercise.
This lecture is considerably shorter than the other lectures we've had so far.
And we're going to do an exercise that is going to take a string that contains a dollar formatted string,
like a dollar sign, a space, commas, and so forth.
And we're going to look at the algorithm to convert it to a floating point number.
How do we convert a string to a floating point number?
So, again, if you haven't done this already, make sure that you have opened the problem statement here for lecture 7.
And so, the input string we're going to get may have dollar signs, spaces, and commas.
It may or may not have a decimal point.
You may assume that the number is well formed, meaning it's not going to have two decimal points.
And it's not an exponential notation, so you don't need to deal with that.
We're not going to use any library functions except for size.
We can use is digit.
Of course, we could have written that ourselves.
And we can use at here.
So this is going to produce a double with the actual value of the string.
So this is an ICO7A.
It's Mo Money.
We're going to put our name on it.
We're going to write the function that's going to return a double.
It's named Mo Money.
It's going to take a const string ref str.
Its result is going to be a double.
So double result.
Let's initialize it to zero.
And let's return result.
And then let's go ahead and try it out.
Make sure we've opened a shell here on A.
Open an integrated terminal.
Okay, that didn't actually open it on A.
We can just do CD A.
And now we're in the correct folder.
I can go ahead and close that so you can see it a little better.
I'm going to do make test.
And notice that it takes in values like $75, $.55, $1.50.75, $1,295.25.
And this is what it expects to get the output of the result out.
Okay, so let's put that away and let's look at the algorithm we need to do.
So what we're going to need to do is we're going to need to process that string.
And we're going to look at every character inside that.
So one way I can look at every character is I can just write a for loop.
So I'm going to say for auto C in STR.
Actually, let's write a traditional for loop.
Size T I equals zero.
Actually, since we've been talking about loops and a half, let's do that.
So size T I equals zero.
And let's actually say size T len equals STR size.
I don't want to just call STR size each time I go.
So while I is less than len, so this is our necessary bounds.
And now let's look at what possible things.
Actually, you know, the while loop is not going to work here because it's going to skip the update at the bottom.
So I'm going to go back to writing it as a for loop.
This is not scripted as you can tell.
So for size T I equals zero.
Len equals STR size.
I less than len plus plus I.
Okay, so we can accept three kinds of things.
Digits, a period, or we can get three kinds of things.
We can get a digit, we can get a period, we can get something that's a space or a dollar sign.
So if we have a period, so when I process this number 150.75, I'm going to be processing, so let's just look down where I have 150.75.
I'm going to be processing two different parts of the number.
I'm going to be parsing the integer part and I'm going to be processing the fractional or the cents part.
So I'm going to be processing the dollars and the cents.
Okay, the dollars and the cents.
So let's create a variable for dollars.
Int dollars is zero and double cents is zero.
Now if I see, so one part of my loop I want to process the whole part. One part of my loop I want to process the cents part.
One part of the loop I want to process the dollars part. One part I want to process the cents part.
So I need to keep track of whether or not I've seen a period.
So what I'm going to say is bool int dollars.
And I'm going to set that to true.
Oh no, int cents.
And I'm going to set that to false.
I'm not in the cents, I'm assuming that I'm in the dollars.
So now I'm ready to look at the characters.
So if str at i is equal to the period, what do I have?
I have my, I have int cents equals true.
And I don't need to process that anymore, so I can continue.
Now if it's not a period, it might not be a digit.
So if not is digit, str at i.
And let's actually save str at i as a character.
So char c equals str at i.
And again, I don't like calling a function multiple times to get the same value.
So if c is not a digit, is what that says.
So if not is digit, not is digit c, then what do we want to do?
We want to just get the next one. We don't need to process it.
So now what do I know if I got to line 22?
I know that I have the digit.
And now I have two possibilities.
If int cents, I'm going to process that one way.
Else, I'm going to process it the other way.
So first, I want to find out what the, so the digits are 0, 1, 2, 3, and so forth.
But they are the characters 0.
And that actually has the ASCII value 48.
So to turn that character digit into a binary digit, I have to subtract 48 from it.
So I'm going to say int digit equals c minus, and instead of 48, I'm going to just say the character is 0.
So that's the same as subtracting 48.
So now I have the binary digit.
Now my dollars equals dollars times 10.
Now dollars is 0 at this time.
Plus my digit.
So this algorithm is the algorithm for converting a sequence of characters into an integer.
Into an integer part.
And there's nothing else inside there. That's all there is to it.
Now, I could actually put this here.
Let's, again, I don't like repeating pieces of code.
So if we get to this piece of code.
If we get to that piece of code.
So if we're in the sense, then, and we can write this.
Then dollars equals dollars times 10 plus digit.
Plus a digit.
Oh no, that's actually that part right there.
So for this part.
So basically what we're doing is we're multiplying the first digit by 1, the second digit by 10, the third digit by 100, the fourth digit by 1000, and so forth.
To get the dollar amount.
Now here, what we want to do is divide the first digit by 10.
Divide the next digit by 100.
Divide the next digit by 1000, and so forth.
Does that make sense?
So that means we need to keep track of 10, 100, 1000.
I'm going to create a variable here I'm going to call the base to do that.
So double base equals 10.
And so the sense is going to be sense plus the digit divided by the base.
And then of course each time the base starts out at 10, now it needs to go to 100.
So base times equals 10.
So 10 times 10, 10 times 10 times 10, 10 times 10 times 10, and so forth.
Okay, so here we've processed the... so let's look at what we've done so far.
We've gone through every character in the string.
We've found out what that character is.
If it's a period, we just set our little flag here, in sense equals true.
And we continue and go up back to the next loop.
If it's not a digit, we continue.
We just skip it, we don't have to process it.
That means when I get to line 23, I know that I have a digit in C,
and I can turn it into a binary number.
So digit here is the binary value of whatever C is.
I've converted the character zero to the number zero.
And here is the base for the numbers we're doing, which are decimal.
So if I'm in cents, I take cents and I add the digit divided by the base.
So 1/10, right?
Then I multiply the base.
So now I'll have the digit divided by 100.
Next time I'll have the digit divided by 1,000, and so forth.
If it's not in cents, if I'm doing the dollars part,
I just multiply the dollars I have already times 10, and I add the digit to it.
Now the result is going to be dollars plus cents.
And we're going to return the result.
So let's see how we did here.
So let's save that.
Let's do make.
No errors.
Let's do make test.
Okay, one of them worked, which is the 75.
This one did not work at all.
Okay, so maybe what I'm going to guess, I'm going to make a quick guess
and make this digit a double.
And I'm also going to make dollars a double as well.
So that's just my first guess.
If not, we'll have to go through and trace through and maybe debug it.
So let's do make test.
And I just made double dollars.
But I still got exactly the wrong answer.
So let me look at my calculation here.
I'm going to turn off and pause this for a few seconds while I think about it,
rather than making you watch me sit here and think about it.
Okay, folks, I see my errors.
You notice on line 24 I have the base set to 10.
Well, this is inside the loop here.
So every time I'm setting it back to 10, it's never going to 100 or 1,000.
So I need to move that double base equals 10 outside of the loop up here.
So let's...
So you'll notice in my test here,
the dollar part was working perfectly fine.
I'm getting the correct number of dollars.
I'm not getting the correct number of cents.
So the cents algorithm was never doing the thousand.
So I was...when I had .55, I was setting the base back to 10 here,
and I was adding .5 and .5 rather than .5 and .05,
which is what this algorithm should have done.
So this should work okay.
Let's try it now.
Make test.
And all of our tests pass correctly.
So let me give you one last look at that code here.
So you can see it all on the screen at once.
And I'm actually going to get rid of a couple comments here
and make this code a little bit more compact,
so you can see it all at once.
Okay, and that will allow you to see all of the function there.
Let me put one more line,
and you can get the whole thing on one screen, I believe.
Not quite, but close.
Yeah, now there's the whole thing on one screen.
Okay, I told you this would be shorter,
only a little bit more than a half an hour.
And I will see you next time for Chapter 8.